بعد تدمير سنوبك خوف كمشاهدينا لا مؤشرات
على انخفاض مستوى تاثير الكارثه بل الامر
اصبح اكثر تعقيدا فعمليات الانقاذ
والاجلاء في المناطق التي غمرها الفيضان
الناجم عن تدمير السد باتت صعبه ومعقده
والسبب ان السرعه نهر النيبل الذي يقع
عليه السد زادت عشره اضعاف عمده منطقه
خرسون الموالي لروسيا فلاديمير سالدو قال
ان اربعه الاف من سكان خرسون الذين تم
اجلائهم موجودون في مراكز ايواء مؤقته
وهناك اكثر منهم علقون
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء ارسلت السلطات الروسيه 45 محطه
توليد كهرباء متنقله الى المناطق المتضرره
في مقاطعه خيرسون وذلك وفق ما افاد مراسل
العربيه كما ارسلت ايضا اربعين مضخه مياه
عملاقه لسحب المياه من شوارع بعض ضواحي
المقاطعه التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
في الجنوب الاوكراني وتتهم موسكو اوكرانيا
بفتح اربعه مجال من سد نيبرو بتروفيسكا
وذلك في وقت واحد لزياده اندفاع المياه من
نهر دنيبرو تجاه ضواحي خرسون لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات